good morning we want to get this session
started and thank you for all being for
being here so my name is Eve rice and on
behalf of the 50th anniversary planning
committee I want to welcome you back to
Yale and to New Haven for the past two
years it has been my great privilege to
chair the committee planning for this
anniversary celebration
[Applause]
to be sure this weekend has been a long
time coming but we are thrilled that
it's here I want to pause for a moment
before we begin the main event to thank
the literally dozens and dozens of
classmates and the extraordinary staff
at the Yale Alumni Association and Yale
conferences and events as well as the
incredible array of individuals at Yale
who have made this weekend and the 50th
anniversary projects possible and of
course a big thank you to to the members
of the 50th anniversary planning
committee women are the classes of 71 72
and 73 whose names you will find in your
programs I want to offer heartfelt
thanks as well to our panelists and
speakers many of whom have traveled very
far to be with us this morning when we
sent the invitations to speak about a
year and a half ago almost to a person
they responded with a resounding yes
clearly something about this anniversary
moment resonated with them and we are
enormous ly grateful for their
participation people often say in an
effort like this that it takes a village
but this has been a little bit akin to a
small city so thank you all I also want
to mention that we have some very
special guests in the audience today
either this morning or through the
weekend at the risk of leaving out
someone I really ought to mention I will
name only a few people here I want to
start with naming the incomparable first
lady of Yale martyr Moret why for
president Peter Salovey who is not here
this morning but will join us later
and I want to acknowledge former
president Rick Levin who was president
of Yale for two decades
[Applause]
and Jane Levin who has taught legions of
Yale students here today and Linda
Lorimer retired vice president and
former trustee of Yale who is also more
importantly right now my co-chair in
leading the fifty women at Yale 150 year
long effort that that this gathering
really has the privilege of kicking off
and I also want to acknowledge Kathryn
Hill if she's in the audience the senior
trustee of the Yale corporation she will
be speaking on Saturday so I think I
will stop there but you can recognize
special guests by their purple tags on
their nametags you will undoubtedly
remember some of them from our time at
Yale and others are people you will want
to meet so please if you see a purple
tag or the blue tag of the speakers
don't be afraid to strike up a
conversation as you will see in the
printed program there's a lot to do in
the next few days
there are thought-provoking panels
campus tours festive receptions and
meals and time to connect with
classmates however and above all we urge
you to use this time on campus in the
way that is most meaningful to you we
wish you a wonderful weekend and a
memorable experience and thank you for
being here I'd like to take a minute now
to introduce president Peter Salovey
who will offer the weekend's opening
remarks and introduce our esteemed panel
so so Peter Salome is the 23rd president
of Yale University and the Chris R juris
professor of psychology at Yale
president Sall avait first arrived in
New Haven as a graduate student in
psychology in the early 1980s that's
when he met his wife Marta who at the
time was a graduate student in the
School of Public Health for over three
decades since he and Marta have made
Yale and New Haven their home and during
these years president Salome has been a
teacher and mentor to scores of students
he is also a renowned researcher known
for the development of a broad framework
called emotional intelligence
[Applause]
in addition he has served the University
and many important roles including Dean
of the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences Dean of Yale College and
provost since becoming president in 2013
president Salome has yet lead Yale's
aspirations to be the global research
university most committed to teaching
and learning notably
during his tenure he opened two new
residential colleges expanded Yale
College enrollment by 15% the biggest
enrollment expansion since guess who
came to Yale
he has also increased access to Yale
education for students worldwide
regardless of their financial background
in addition he has advanced innovative
teaching scholarship and research on
campus and amplified Yale's partnerships
in countries across Africa and other
continents around the globe all these
efforts have been in keeping with Yale's
mission to improve the world today and
for future generations please join me in
welcoming president Sall of a
[Applause]
[Applause]
Thank You Eve good morning everyone
I am thrilled to see so many alumni and
friends back on campus with us today and
it is really a privilege to officially
welcome you to the first women in Yale
College of 50th anniversary celebration
so as you know this weekend is the first
event in a year-long commemoration
marking 50 years of college education in
Yale College and a hundred and fifty
years of female students at the
University and so on behalf of the
University I'd like to recognize the
dedicated volunteers who put this
weekend's program together and who are
planning events over the course of the
entire academic year you all know Eve
Hart rice Yale College class of 1973 and
I just want to add my own thank you to
her for her hard work she is a yale
trustee she is chair of the 50th
anniversary committee and has worked
tirelessly to put together a truly
impressive program
I want to thank Linda Koch Lorrimer a
1977 graduate of Yale Law School and a
retired vice president of the University
of former Yale trustee she is the
co-chair of the steering committee for
50 women at Yale 150 and together Eve
and Linda have been working with a
dedicated team of alumni and students
and faculty and staff to plan this
entire year so please join me in one
more thank you to Eve and to Linda and
all who have made this program possible
and this year possible
[Applause]
so we're here to mark a moment of great
significance in Yale's history it's a
history that you lived it's a history
that you helped make it's a story of how
Yale changed forever when a group of
young women were willing to be the first
now to be clear there had been women at
Yale before but as many alumni from the
graduate and professional schools recall
everything changed when you the first
undergraduate women arrived you changed
not only Yale College but you changed
the entire University and it was not
easy there are obstacles there were
missed opportunities there were mistakes
your remarkable success at Yale and ever
since is a testament to your strength
integrity and talent it models
resilience and self-reliance for our
current students in the past 50 years
Yale has continued to open its doors
open its doors wider and to push the
frontiers of knowledge and understanding
further one thing has led to another
today our students come from all 50
states from over 120 countries around
the world the class of 2023 is the most
diverse in Yale's history over half
identify as a racial or ethnic minority
and altogether they speak more than 60
languages one in five members of the
first-year class qualify for Federal
Pell grants for low-income students the
number of pell eligible students has
doubled in just five years
17% this year are the first in their
families to attend college that's a 75%
increase in five years
what they share in common is a desire to
make the most of yells opportunities to
engage with new ideas to make a
difference in the lives of others to
shape the future of our world and they
look to you as role models they see how
you forged ahead in business law science
the arts many other fields and in a
world that was not always welcoming or
accepting they take inspiration in your
accomplishments all around us is the
Yale you helped create 50 years ago
because when you walked through Phelps
gate in 1969 you showed us that
excellence is what matters and that it
takes many different people to seek
light and truth that is your legacy so
this weekend is an opportunity an
opportunity for the entire Yale
community to celebrate you and to
celebrate the history that you helped
make it's a chance to hear and record
your stories so that we can understand
the changes you've brought to yell and
to society and it's about looking ahead
as well to the great chapters yet to be
written and to the history yet to be
made this weekend this celebration is
but a small measure of what Gale owes
you the trailblazers who led yell into a
new era thank you for coming back thank
you for being here but thank you
especially for being the first now to
begin our program what I'd like to do is
welcome our distinguished moderator and
panelists to the stage our moderator is
Margaret Warner Yale class of 1971
Margaret is a former chief globe
affairs correspondent of PBS newshour a
former member of the Yale Corporation
and a senior fellow at the Yale Jackson
Institute for global affairs she is
joined by Brenda juban who earned her
PhD from Yale in 1973 and who served as
a Dean of Moores College from 1970 to
1973 brenda is the former president of
brevis press Nancy Malkiel professor of
history emeritus at Princeton University
and former dean of the college at
Princeton is the author of the book keep
the damn women out which I hope you all
have Kurt Schmoke Yale College class of
1971 is the president of the University
of Baltimore Kurt is the former mayor of
Baltimore former dean of Howard
University School of Law and a former
member of yells Board of Trustees the
Yale corporation Gary Trudeau received
his BA from Yale in 1970 and his MFA in
1973 he's a Pulitzer Prize winning
author and artist and creator of the
comic strips bull tails and Doonesbury
John Wilkinson received his BA from Yale
College in 1960 and his master's degree
in education in 1963 John is the former
associate dean and former dean of
undergraduate affairs in Yale College
and former secretary of the university
so please join me in welcoming to the
state welcoming them to the stage and
welcoming everyone of you back to ya
[Applause]
Peter thank you my fellow panelists it
thank you for that lovely introduction
[Music]
alright I just have to put it closer
thank you so much Peter for that great
introduction no all right I'm not and
I'm not in charge of sound can someone
resolve this how about that yes okay one
more time Peter thank you for that
lovely introduction and it's great to be
back here I remember coming here often
elicits a Wednesday night for the Yale
Law School Film Society
and welcome I'm glad Peter introduced
and let you know how are just panelists
and why they're all here because they
all either were part of it actually all
were part of it in some way
decision-making and execution so today
we're really going to you know Yale have
been since 1718 an all-male institution
and then suddenly it seemed to people on
the outside that in 1968 the corporation
took a vote and voted to move towards
co-education so today we're going to
hear about how that happened and how
different groups on campus felt about it
and then of course how it was carried
out and I'm going to start with John no
I'm going to start with Nancy forgive me
so so you've researched and written the
definitive book on co-education not only
here but in several other Ivy's
Princeton and Dartmouth for sure and
there so let me just get right to the
big question I have
there's been so much mythology about why
Yael voted to go co-ed what do you think
the truth is no but I mean you I'm an
historian I'm not sure I'm in the
business of truth but I'll tell you I
would say there are two main reasons and
one background reasons the main reasons
which I'll describe our admissions
number one and competition with
Princeton number two the background is
the context of the 1960s and all the
changes underway in the 60s that meant
that by the end of the decade a place
like Yale for only passing resemblance
to what it had been at the beginning of
the decade first admissions what yell
experience in the latter part of the
1960s like Princeton was that the best
men in high schools they called them the
best voice these best boys no longer
wanted to go to all-male schools this is
the point at which Harvard which had
been going neck-and-neck with Princeton
and Yale and admissions up through the
early 1960s begins to pull away because
there are girls up the street at
Radcliffe and so Yale like Princeton
decided that it was important to admit
women not because of a mission to
educate women not because of a moral
commitment to equality for women but
rather because admitting women was a
strategic move to enable Yale like
Princeton to regain its hold on these
best boys yell like Princeton couldn't
abide the notion that the best boys were
not any longer as interested as they had
been in coming to New Haven the
competition with Princeton now Kingman
Brewster starts this off
the elf faculty others at Yale certainly
the Yale Daily News understand in the
early in mid 1960s it would be a good
thing to bring undergraduate women to
New Haven but the president and the
corporation were certainly not having
any of that however the opportunity
arose through a mutual connection for
kingman brewster to begin exploring with
alan simpson the president of Vassar the
possibility of moving Vassar from
Poughkeepsie to New Haven and there was
about a 10-month serious study
undertaken beginning it was announced in
December of 1966 very high-level
president trustees faculty
administrators of what would be involved
in bringing Vassar to New Haven and some
sort of coordinate relationship with
Yale now Bob Cohen the President of
Princeton finds out about this and his
response is to go up to Sarah Lawrence
College and begin talking to the
president Sarah Lawrence about the
possibility of doing a study of moving
Sarah Lawrence to Princeton Sarah
Lawrence says no thank you
Vassar eventually of course said no
thank you but Sarah Lawrence says not
even a study
Princeton's more serious response to
Vassar Yale was to commissioned a study
of a data-driven analytic study of the
feasibility and desirability of
co-education at Princeton a study
undertaken by Gardner Patterson an
economist in the Woodrow Wilson School
so after Vassar in November of 1967 says
no thank you to Yale Brewster says well
we'll establish our own coordinate
College for women and he spends the next
10 months musing about what that might
entail 4-year undergraduate that's one
option there were a number of others and
he wrote some position papers but
essentially nothing was happening now
the powders
report is completed published in the
Princeton Alumni Weekly at the end of
September 1968 a copy comes to Brewster
he reads it in he sees the Princeton
could be serious about Co education so
from the end of September till the
middle of November with no process and
no planning
Brewster gets the Yale Corporation and
the L faculty to vote in favor of
co-education for September of 1969
now Princeton at this point is going
through its very deliberate process
oriented consultation with alumni all
around the country in January of 67 the
Princeton Trustees vote for Co education
in principle and they tell president
going to come back when he's ready and
tell them how they're going how I'd like
to do it and he does that in late April
of 1969 at which point of course Yale
has already made its decisions on admits
to the class of 73
now if Princeton had done what Princeton
would normally do the Princeton trustees
in late April would have said we're
going to embark on co education we'll
spend a lot of time getting organized
for it and we'll do it first September
of 1970 but they couldn't do that
because the women were coming to Yale in
September of 1969 and so in late April
of 1969 Princeton decides to bring women
in in the fall of 1969 well I agree with
Nancy completely Yale had no plan and as
a consequence had a flawed process and
we did it because the rumor in New Haven
was that Princeton in fact was going to
go co-educational in the fall of 1969
now I agree with Nancy's assessment of
some of the reasons but there there are
a couple of others that I think we're
really very important
we then had a student body which had
become it reached its maturity its
majority began 818 rather than 21
the Yale students of that period we're
not going to let the administration tell
them how they were going in of their
lives and the one thing that the Yale
students wanted all those virtually all
those men they wanted Yale to be
co-educational and and the students the
students drove that with co-ed week and
in demonstrations and great assistants
and in part of that reason I'm convinced
was Yale was in the process in its
efforts to diversify it discovered
public schools in a big way and we went
from 2/3 private boarding to 2/3 public
all of those public school students and
a lot of the day students had gone to
co-educational institutions they had
never encountered single sex education
until they arrived at Yale it was not
something they regard as normal or
natural or acceptable now I wouldn't add
one thinking and Nancy mentions this in
her book and I should say if you haven't
read it yet it's great and and read it
it's a fantastic
it's not just Yale and the Ivy's it's
also the Seven Sisters it deals with
with those institutions which already
had coordinate colleges and it has a
wonderful section on on Oxford and
Cambridge and how they approach this and
the other book I want to recommend is
and Perkins here it just it just came
out and it's a wonderful book and if you
are have an abiding interest in how
these decisions were made these are the
two books to read you know one of the
things that struck me as I read okay one
of the things that struck me as I read
Nancy's book was that our institutions
became co-educational for pragmatic
reasons these were not principled
decisions
the only these were not principal
decisions these were pragmatic decisions
and it I don't know of any president of
any college or university who actually
made the statement that sir Eric Ashby
of Clare College Cambridge said the
motivating force behind the college is
blowing this delete on the issue he said
what's the grave and great inequality
and injustice being done this this was
this was not a statement was being made
in the United States it was made it was
made in Cambridge interesting
so Gary and Kurt were undergraduates you
were in the transition Gary
class of seventy myself I'm sorry myself
also with Kurt in the class of 71 I know
that I can't ask you to speak for all
men undergraduates but I'm it's our
lease it's not fair but I'm going to
Gary I'll start with you because you
were one class ahead was it as as John
describes that there was this
groundswell of from where you sat and
sketched and was there a groundswell
among the the student population
absolutely absolutely and and one of the
most remarkable precursors to women
actually coming to Yale as as real
students was when they came as fake
students for coed week and that was
organized by an undergraduate when you
think of the administration involved in
bringing hundreds of girls and clearing
out our rooms and making them available
to women it's quite quite a remarkable
achievement but it really put a stake in
the ground and all of us particularly
you know I was coming off my tenth year
of single sex education it was quite a
revelation to me and I was so taken by
it that I went to Wellesley
co-ed week where I was one of 50 men
just to see what it would be like to be
in the minority and my my first class
there was an art class where I was asked
to be the model it was like to be a
curiosity before before the women did
when they came but I was also from my
little bubble of prep-school privilege I
was perfectly prepared to go through my
11th year of single-sex education
without without complaint but when it
became known that it was actually going
to happen I think that a great many of
us thought well this is a new feature
for Yale it's not maybe maybe folks like
Kurt who actually joined the
co-education Committee and where were
intimately involved had it had a
different view but I think most of us
really saw it in terms of new dating
opportunities and it was it was it was
something that you know happened all at
once I sometimes think of co-education
emails a little bit like the Affordable
Care Act it was something that was
debated for decades and then it was
rushed forward all at once and had had a
very bumpy rollout and then once it
happened and was a success
everybody was angry on both sides
because it was a half-measure
and people became really angry very
quickly by you know halfway through the
man and women men and women by by the
small number and and I think the issue
of social equity that Yale had a
responsibility to educate women just out
of fairness and for the good of society
that only kind of arrived I would say
and I'm always speaking from my one year
but that sort
began to become a very important issue
about halfway through that first year of
education Kurt what about you you know
well Margaret let me first start by
noting there in our alma mater there's a
line that says how bright will seem
through memories haze on this matter
there's more haze than brightness for me
but it was because of reading
Nancy's book and and and back there that
I started to have my memory refreshed
and as Gary noted
I was actually appointed to the first
planning committee it was called the
Planning Committee for co-education
headed by Alva Wasserman at the time and
so you can blame me that occurred in the
early years but you know what was going
through a quite a dramatic for Yale a
dramatic period of transition at the
time as John mentioned in the 1950s here
what passed for diversity was a white
male public school student from the
Midwest
[Music]
so then and in the 60s the early 60s
there were a few african-american male
students on campus and I think although
Sam Chauncey who you'll hear from I
guess at the later will probably explain
well I wasn't sure how I got appointed
to the committee co-education planning
committee I was a sophomore at the time
honestly I don't remember but I think it
was because and and could probably give
you more detail on this that there was
some sense that after an
african-american male having gone
through a cultural change or lived
through a cultural change at on campus
might in some way give an indication
although we race and gender very
different issues but that might in some
way add to an insight about the change
that was going to occur to kind of how
do you adapt to a cultural change that's
going to occur on campus gary is
absolutely right that the for most of
the men here was overwhelming support I
mean they're very few certainly no
organized opposition to this there was
my recollection some irreverent moments
if if some of you may remember the the
Yale band marching band at one time did
their own statement about the potential
merger scene Yale and Vassar if maybe I
won't explain it but in any event it was
an irreverent moment that where they
commented on it but the bottom line is
that most of the men were very
supportive and and we did I think the
notes from the planning committee
that generally my votes were on the
right side of history here that the
there was an argument at one time in the
early planning process about
establishing a separate College at Yale
for women rather than having women in
all of the colleges and that that was
voted down but a lot of debate of
planning and I think the decisions that
we made were the right one though the
road was bumpy and some might disagree
about the preparation but I want to get
miss Brenda in this excuse me and Brenda
juban so you were a young philosophy
instructor and you taught both men and
then when it went co-ed women and you
were named the first woman ever to be
the Dean of a residential college so how
did it once the women arrived what
change did you detect both as a teacher
and as a sort of you know dorm counselor
and enforcer
let me start back one step I was also a
graduate student at Yale and graduate
students at that point were really
second-class citizens Yale College was
the center of the universe the Graduate
the graduate school was definitely
peripheral to the main thrust of the
university within the graduate school
women were even worse off we were all
corralled into Helen Hadley hole that
architectural masterpiece and we're told
among other things that we had to wear
skirts to go to the library which most
women found a little bit off but that
was the old university graduate school
when Yale became co-ed and when I was
named Dean I became part of an entirely
new universe this was a community a
vibrant community
men and women yes of course they were
bumps in the road and you know and there
were a few men who wished me not to ever
have been appointed thank you very much
but in general it was a vibrant lively
place and I am personally very grateful
for Co education because without that I
would probably still have been a third
fourth class citizen in the Graduate
School okay now when women came yeah I
taught you know in the philosophy
department my first class with a woman I
had one woman in a class of m8020 and I
thought oh dear you know I sort of hope
that she's a really good student and she
wasn't and I thought well that's too bad
just get over it and you know she's
gonna be and why not have an average
woman not every woman has to be you know
superwoman but in general you know I
didn't have problems on the teaching
front as far as you know being Dean was
concerned I wish I had had all women in
the sense that we would have freed up so
much time I spent all my time dealing
with the men but the man had all the
problems the man needed the deans
excuses
the man you know needed that
recommendation for Harvard Law School
which they were never going to get into
but daddy said they had to apply anyway
so this was basically my experience in a
nutshell I thought the land needed more
hand-holding and guidance than the woman
much much more much much more the women
the women who came in first of all of
course they were hand-picked and so you
had women who were you know strong and
bright and whatnot but they got there
and for instance in Morris we had the
strangest assortment of women living
together in an entryway how they could
ever get along was beside me but they
did they got along fine nobody came
saying I have to move from this room
because I can't stay
and X or Y the band on the other hand
would say I have to be moved because
he's too noisy I can't stand him anymore
so you know as I said I would have had
all the free time in the world my
dissertation we've been finished well in
the peers before if I had only women can
I comment on the superwoman labels that
the women got tagged with I think I
guess you have to put the mic right
about okay I have to find that sweet
spot is that is that okay I just wanted
to comment on the super women label that
who gave it to was a Time magazine and
it was initially a little intimidating
from from from a male perspective but
once once the women arrived even though
it was a an infusion of high IQ
individuals but most was what was most
disruptive to the to the male culture
was the high etq that the women just
seemed more developmentally mature I
always had the sense that they could see
right through me and it wasn't a pretty
picture and and so it was and with I
just that was the only way in which I
thought they were actually over time I
thought that was a tremendous
contribution to the overall culture but
difficult for some man Kurt oh oh I'm
sorry but difficult for some man do
great fruit well general eyes because
the you know our experiences were so
different when I came in I came from a
public high school that was all-male
$4000 boys yeah and it was kind of weird
but but so this was not a shocking
experience to me and and also my
experience here was slightly different
than some of my other colleagues because
I came in
as a football player it's so that was a
traditional Yale institution so I didn't
feel a disconnect from the place the way
some of my other colleagues did and with
respect to women I see the congresswoman
coming in now I mean I know that there
there definitely were some high-powered
people but I didn't get a sense of that
now maybe I didn't because I didn't read
Time magazine at the time New York Times
or whatever it was but but I did a real
sense of friendship and camaraderie and
and and not a disconnect that some
others felt I agree the men were
accustomed to being pampered and they
came to the L College Dean's office all
the time asking for help the women who
came came to tell us how to do our job
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and and I I remember the first time I
had an undergraduate woman have a tear
rolled down her cheek she was so
embarrassed and I pulled out a Kleenex
and I said I have about ten boxes of
Kleenex here I've been using for years
for men don't apologize for tears
I think I don't think the women had any
more or fewer problems than the men I
think the women were much more reluctant
to express them good well event and I
think that was part of the part of the
culture I think the women were much less
willing to express their issues and
their problems than the men because they
had come to this new strange place and
they had to be resilient and they were
Oh again John and also Nancy what can
you tell us about the selection process
I mean over grades or something but what
was I've heard again there's a lot of
Mythology about what Elgar Wasserman was
looking for in particular and anyone
here shed light on it well what what
Elga and Sam Chauncey clearly agreed on
was that they were looking for something
beyond the credentials you might
normally expect in terms of academic
achievement and leadership in high
school they were looking for people who
were tough who were gritty who were
resilient who could in fact survive in
this environment and they were very
explicit about that and both of them
played a significant role in the review
of applications for women at Princeton
the phrase that was often used was
people who had been American field
service students abroad was one marker
for the kind of grit and ability to
adjust the unfamiliar circumstances the
theory as enunciated by Wasserman and
Chauncey was he was really going to take
a lot of strength and adaptability for
women to manage at this institution that
I - the process was the selection of
Jackie Robinson as the first
african-american in in major league
baseball that Branch Rickey the the
owner of the team wasn't just looking
for the best athlete there was a
combination of characteristics that they
wanted and somebody who was going to be
able to stand up to a tough environment
as well as being a great athlete so they
were definitely looking for you know
outstanding academic achievement but it
was that plus some characteristic we're
all gonna be blushing in this auditorium
but
anyway Gary you wanted to say something
oh you just looked very very interested
so John anyone chime in on this what was
the thinking by a behind the lack of
preparation I mean I work I certainly
was there thinking I mean we girls or
women we would have there were no
women's bathrooms say in this well there
probably was in this building but in
most buildings so you had to run back
from class to your dorm room or suite to
use the bathroom the women who were very
athletically minded were just stunned I
think Ann Perkins has a great anecdote
about this in her book you know the
young woman comes in and says well so I
want to join the hockey team and the
varsity and the director of athletics
just looked dumbfounded there been no
arrangements made for or anticipation
that women athletes had the same
aspirations as men and would need the
facilities that would you know serve
them if they were going to be the
superstars they want it to be so what
was the thinking there was their lack of
thinking my a Wellesley classmate who
became a professor at at the University
is SUNY Stony Brook who went Oxford
several years ago before they had become
co-educational and the fellows voted to
make her an honorary man so she could
attend those events that the fellows all
of them were male attended it's some as
I pulled the story to us a few weeks ago
I thought you know the lack of planning
we we brought in 500 women and we
treated them like honorary men the
planning took place largely I'm sorry
Kurt a lot of the planning took place
after you were here because
we it was a rush job and we probably
should have had a couple years of
planning but I don't think the
undergraduate student body at that time
would have permitted the administration
to wait two years but Nancy
didn't-didn't Brewster actually set the
terms when he said this is our R&D year
this is this is an experiment Gary can
you explain more more clearly and I said
my understanding was that was that
Brewster viewed the first year of
co-education is as the R&D year that it
was it was the year in which he expected
to experiment and and I you know correct
me if I'm wrong Curt but I think the the
co education committee was supposed to
be doing the field research and
gathering that the data and finding out
what was good and what was bad and then
reporting back to him the problem was he
didn't do anything with that report so
there was another two or three years
before we were on the past the four
education well if Brewster thought about
this I haven't found it in the written
record I think he just figured yeah I
was gonna do this and it would work
itself out some way or another and the
women would get here and would help you
figure out how to do this but as gary
said he was not interested in the
reports from the co education committee
and so with just work itself out yeah
and I think in both Nancy's and Anne's
book that is demonstrated by the tension
that curve between kingman brewster and
Elga Wasserman she tried her best not
only to get these reports directly to
him but to elevate her status at the
University and he continued to keep her
a special assistant rather than as an
Associate Dean or as a Dean
or as a senior vice president and so
there was attention there the other
thing that that's not really captured in
anything that I've read to the pressure
that he was under by alumni and some
trustees who were against this he had
the votes the corporation at one time
with some major leaders to move this
thing forward but there was some real
opposition and a question about what
that might mean for the future financial
status of the place and I know that that
was a concern that he had let's do it
now and you know ask forgiveness later
yes Nancy which is in a way
characteristic of the way Brewster
operated on other fronts would a really
deliberate careful planner have made the
remark he made about the unlikelihood of
a black revolutionary getting a fair
trial in the United States would he have
made the remarks he made about his
opposition to the Vietnam War probably
not if he was being careful in working
not to stir up a position but Brewster
was under attack from so many quarters
over his stance on the war stance on the
Panthers willingness to open the campus
to the demonstrators on may day over his
unwillingness to silence or fire William
Sloane coffin
so co-education was just one other thing
where people were really angry at him
and my sense is that because of alumni
anger at Brewster on so many fronts his
his ability in a maneuver on
co-education was more limited than it
might have been if he had had a freer
hand well give us a sense of the Alumni
I guess I turned to you John again how
fierce was the opposition what form did
it take
was really the overriding objection well
because because of the lack of planning
and because of the lack of planning and
the immediacy of the decision I think
those who were very much in favor of
co-education were very pleasantly
surprised those who were opposed to
co-education were very unpleasantly
surprised and and the opposition was
more imagined than real it didn't take
very long for our alumni to think that
in fact they had daughters who were
going to get into Yale and I understand
full well why the presidents of these
institutions were afraid of that because
sometimes the opposition was very vocal
but indeed the opposition was not very
deep and did it did it have a theme well
it was hard to sort it out at Yale
because he said there were lots of other
issues we're dealing with Panthers we
were dealing with with the Vietnam War
we were dealing with the changes in in
in the admissions decisions the change
in the democracy of the undergraduate
student body so that there were there
were a number of people coming out of
that hornet's nest mad as hell at
kingman for a whole range of decisions
co education was only one of them I did
a did it abate after a year or two yes
thanks to the leadership of people like
Fred Rolla wasn't Mel Chapin and there
were a number of alumni who stepped up
to the front and they really took over
and and and created the crazy
Association to be all alumni which
became comprehensive and represent the
entire university including graduate
student and has flourished it's a very
supportive organization I just want to
say you know this in context about the
change yeah look I think that Yale
didn't have its first Jewish Corporation
member until the late 60s
so this place and when I was here I was
still listening to some old blues that
were talking about Yale admitting to
many people from New York which was code
you know and so you know there was
serious opposition to this kind of
change going on so I think it really has
to be placed in context it seems like
kind of an easy both hasty decision that
he made but it was pretty dramatic and
revolutionary for this place that was
tied into such always and Brendan was
mentioning about the the college I mean
the graduate school I mean it was kind
of a peripheral thing here I think Rick
and xi and you know it's helped during
his tenure here to make the entire
University the place when you say Yale
it's not just the college you know the
entire university but all those things
that came about slowly and so this was a
very very dramatic change for an
institution it was kind of hidebound and
and looking mainly to the past could I
just say one other it really is
important I think it's really important
to put this in the context I mentioned
earlier that the public field population
doubled the student of color population
was doubling almost every year for over
a five year period and the Jewish and
Catholic populations during that period
doubled as well so it's a yell by the
time you arrive was a very very
different place from the one that I went
to from 1956 to 1960 did you want to
jump in Gary no you always look so you
know you look spellbound and as if
you're on the verge of saying something
so I'll put you on the spot I'm dying to
ask
I don't recall so I'm going to ask you
did bull tail's deal with co-education
what degree was a good grist for bull
tails I tried to research this on Google
but it was hard to follow I tried to
research it too and I found I published
two collections of bull tails when I was
a student and I dug out the second one
and the less we say about that
the better other than I'm so so sorry or
whatever small toxic contribution to
your experience I made what preceded
that when I first started thinking about
well what does this mean for us as
satirist on the air record which is it
still is the humor magazine and we
gathered here at Yale a few weeks early
to try to get out an early issue about
women coming to Yale and we enlisted the
help of a friend of my mother's who was
a professional model runway model and
she was like 511 and had three feet of
blonde hair and thought well this is a
perfect avatar for the women that will
be arriving we put her on the cover as
as eye candy with two words the girls
and then inside we had four profiles of
supposedly incoming freshmen and of
course we didn't know any but we you
know we and we needed pictures so so we
enlisted the help of our legacy
girlfriends and we were all too happy to
make fun of the competition so we we
took their pictures and we wrote
profiles for them and I I can't imagine
what it would have been like I mean you
didn't we're making fun of them or we've
met any of them and were these real
women coming to Yale no no no they were
just girls we knew oh oh babe yes so
that was my opening move and and and I
going back and looking at some of those
those early strips they there's no
hiding it because it was in the Welcome
Center there's a strip where Mike
arrives
in college and and finds that through
some error in administrative error he
his roommate is a woman that was you
think would set up some pretty
interesting storylines you would think
would set up some pretty interesting
storylines but I think the less we talk
about where that went
the better I think the strip did become
kind of a symbol of the old order in
some people's minds and I think I was
rewarded for that by being included in a
book called women at Yale which was
written by two sociologists grad
students did you encounter that Nancy in
your research and was written by to two
really interesting sociology grad
students named pepper Schwartz and Janet
leaver and they were into sort of
participatory fieldwork and so they
actually went out on dates they went to
mixers they went on road trips they all
matter of humiliation just to get a
taste for it and they interviewed a lot
of real students including myself and I
remember coming out of that interview it
must have been in January halfway
through the year and being very
uncomfortable with my answers they are
the kind of answers I would have given a
year earlier two years earlier and
probably answers that we're
representative of a lot of Yale seniors
at that time and I think and again you
have to correct correct me on the
chronology but I think that there was a
gathering there was some women's
gathering in February a conference I'm
in the midst of whatever time the
disruption that well at any rate I you
know this is something that we that I
started thinking about remember the
women's movement only arrived on campus
as the undergraduates did I think if you
had asked the typical female
undergraduate in the fall of 1969 are
you a feminist I think some of them
would had to think about it and and
some of them might not even known what
what that meant as a belief system if
you would ask them do you think women
should enjoy the same rights and
opportunities as men well that's a
no-brainer that's why they were there
that's how they got there but the actual
creation of a movement of women reaching
out to one another had not haveno hadn't
even happened on the campus was hard to
find women's groups in the early part of
it was all the non freshman half of us
didn't know one another because we were
split up you know in different colleges
so that was in other words we hadn't had
the old campus I guess bonding
experience whatever you'd call it Kurt
were you about to add something the
planning committee Oh Oh what was a
deliberate decision of the planning to
make sure that women were in all the
colleges rather than in a single College
from for those who transfer it as well
as those who came in as freshmen so in
that in the end I didn't someone have
women or no they all did yes there was a
decision on the part of the president to
to make Trumbull college a woman's
college and he appeared before the
Trumbull students who made sure that
would not happen and it was and it was
understandable because Kaman graduated
in 1941 from 1941 to 1968 at that point
or 69 the residential college system had
come into its own
so people identified very strongly in
fact I remember some of you when you
went to meetings in the hockey rate
protesting one thing or another you
would introduce yourself not with a
surname you'd be married from silliman
Helen from Trumbull so the colleges had
become very strong identifying places or
our undergraduates say when Kingman
tried to take trouble away from the men
they would not let it happen
so Brenda talk a little bit more about
what we're talking about here the sort
of social fabric the the the community
and the way it was organized because you
probably had am i right a lot more
students pouring out their heart or
complaining than most would hear not so
much about social life social life was
like rooming things that we overlooked
things that we overlooked
there was a double next to the deans
apartment it would anyway a double room
next to the deans apartment which
actually turned into like the honeymoon
suite I'm proud to announce by the way
that all those couples who are still
married occupied that that double but no
I was not hearing you know sort of oh
you know I I I'm having problems
socially I said the women just were not
complaining the men were not complaining
so much socially as academically their
academic complaints that they weren't
they weren't complaining about the women
they were complaining they couldn't do
the work didn't complain because they
did the work and you got to graduation
and it was like you know so-and-so
woman's summa [ __ ] laude so-and-so guy
barely squeaked by etc but you know this
was I said what I was so surprised
though was that the women got along I
said you just wouldn't have believed and
why did you think that was they were so
different in terms of personality I mean
you would not think that they could
actually socialize they could have lunch
together I mean they live next to each
other wouldn't that be enough I mean if
you really didn't like that one so much
but no they seemed that ass to be and
that they made little groups cohorts and
I guess felt comfortable that way
the one change to the social life of
course was dating and the road trip but
I'm going to ask Gary and Kirk to
describe really and I never went on a
road trip Gary I did would even
hitchhike to Smith and those early
mixers that I went to he's confessing
that he did go on road I did those you
know there were there were mixers where
bus loads of young women were brought to
you and but there were also the mixers
to which we were invited at women's
campuses it was a horror show I mean
there's there's no other way to describe
it
and and I was very I was very shy and
and I was an art guy there's I think you
know there's one of the things that Yael
did for me was that it made it okay to
be an art guy there's it's no accident
that women have been at the art school
for 150 years I think that that art as a
discipline was seen as soft unserious
and but it allowed me to create a
connection with the women friends that I
made some subsequently and in my
sophomore junior year and it was it was
you know it was something that that that
you could find support for once you got
to you because I've been through all
these seven years of of macho prep
school culture so it was it was a bit of
a relief so I think now we're going to
open it up to questions from the
audience and if someone moving around
with the mic yes so in the experience of
women that Princeton was a very
different you know it and I say this not
as a chauvinist for Princeton but it
went somewhat better it didn't go
better in all the ways that it didn't go
well yeah which is to say you're the
only woman in a class and the instructor
asks you for the woman's point of view
you know in literature or psychology
maybe but in math and physics
it didn't go better in the sense that no
a woman walks into a study room in the
library and the large number of men
there start giggling and she leaves and
never goes back again
it didn't go better in all of that sort
of thing happened at Princeton all of
the unease of the women when their great
friend during the week brings a great
friend from Smith or Wellesley on the
weekend all of that was descriptive of
Princeton the ways in which it went
better are several first of all
Princeton had a hundred and seventy-six
women
in 170 women in the first year Yale had
576 now you might say just 170 women
what that allowed was first of all we
had the housing to accommodate the women
and then we quite quickly acquired new
living space as we turned the Princeton
in the hotel into a dormitory at
residential college we built new
dormitories so the intense crunch on
housing space here were men and women
were so overcrowded in rooms meant for
fewer students was not the case at
Princeton it went better at Princeton in
that the woman hired as an assistant
dean of students to work on the
development of co-education the
acculturation of the women's students
was highly respected by the president
the provost the Dean of the college
the Dean of Students who listened to her
who acted on her recommendations
none of the marginalization that Elga
Wasserman experienced and it went better
at Princeton in the sense that this
woman Dean was able to get to know
personally every single one of those
hundred and seventy women students to
listen to their stories and experiences
and then to formulate institutional
responses to improve the situation as
smart and effective as Ella Wasserman
was she couldn't get to know 576
students personally and as has been said
certainly the president was not
listening to her recommendations so some
of those are some of the ways in which I
think it was easier at Princeton which
is pretty paradoxical there is nothing
in the history and traditions of that
place that would lead you to believe
that Co education would have gone well I
[Laughter]
remind you that Nancy still at Princeton
I mean just so you know the institution
well so how are we doing questions here
all right I think let's go right here
and if you just introduce yourself and
your year now I'm Kelsey Kaufman and I
graduated in the 71 and so I love the
opportunity of celebrating the past as a
chance to think about discrimination
today there are hundreds of thousands of
our sisters who are not welcome here at
Yale and those are post incarcerated
women a number of years ago I started
the college program at the Indiana
women's prison ran it for quite a number
of years still work with my former
students when one of my outstanding
students applied here to Yale University
for graduate school but her application
was not meant to say do you have a
question yeah okay so Kurt smoke yes
ma'am
I would love to hear you speak about
parallels between discrimination against
post incarcerate
people now compared to discrimination
against women back in our era just real
quick
you know Mike my current job is a
president University of Baltimore we
actually have a degree granting program
and to Jessup Correctional Institution
right outside the city and so we have
take young men who are and they within
three years of release and they are
admitted to our academic programs and
then when they release they come on to
our campus and to complete their degree
so we are reaching out to returning
citizens and we do have a number of our
professors who are also involved with
women and who are incarcerated now so I
can't speak for Yale but I don't think
that that should be a barrier to
admission and I'm sure that other alumni
would support making sure that that
barrier doesn't exist yes right there
just you I'm Lea Greenwald I am from the
class of 72
could you where's AVI SOI fir could you
where's AVI SOI fir I mean my
understanding right but right this
minute I don't I thought he was even
going to be here but my understanding
from friends of mine in my class who
were freshmen without women was that
avi did it all and so now you know
that's the impression of an
undergraduate at the time but perhaps
you could add his his role some
information about his role in the
lead-up to the announcement that okay
women come on in thanks Kurt well
obviously fur and Derek share and in
fact can you just explain in a nutshell
who they Derek Derek here and obviously
from with the two organized organized
the the co-education week and and avi
also was a strong strong advocate for Co
education he probably was the most
outspoken advocate for Co education and
I'm sorry he's not here because they
have a lot to say there's a great lot of
information about avi there I don't know
you know whether he could have been here
but if you'd like to know you're
absolutely right he was a leader in this
effort and I think is captured pretty
well in there right I just want to say a
moment avi was invited
he sent his regrets he invited I'm not
sure he may not regret this because
they're how many people in the audience
but he said if any of you want to
contact him he'd be glad to hear from
you so but he was invited and we're
sorry he's not here
Thank You Eve the lady in the striped
shirt
I think no that's he I'm sorry I meant
you thank you my name is Maggie Kuhn
class of 1973 Calhoun grace hopper I'm
hoping an perkins is in the audience she
here kind of as a follow-up I had the
distinct impression from reading your
book that Kingman Brewster displayed a
lot of resistance to co-education and so
I'd love to hear a little bit more of
your reflection on that because I sort
of got a little bit different impression
from our panelists if your book will it
willing to comment
sure
I'm a-standing
the woman I am I never met Kingman
Brewster he had he left before I came
here as a freshman but in and in reading
about him I was so struck and and
listening to those of you whom I
interviewed about him so struck by the
admiration students had for him his
stands on the Vietnam War which were
incredibly courageous and and I think I
see them a little differently than you
Nancy and that I think they were very
thoughtful he would go off and write his
president's report on Martha's Vineyard
and really think about the place of a
university in welcoming students of
color who had not been included at a
place like Yale before in taking stands
on issues such as Vietnam but I I do
think there was a blind spot when it
came to women and for me the answer
really lies and the incredible
insularity of many of the men at Yale so
Gary has talked about how he had been at
an all-male school for 11 years
so Brewster went from all-male prep
school to all-male Yale to nearly all
male
Harvard Law School back to Yale where he
appointed all of his closest advisors as
men who had gone to all male Yale and
the trustees were men who had gone to
OEM male Yale so there's no and he
marries a woman whose father went to
all-male Yale and she went to Vassar so
there's not an ability to see beyond
that world of men and I do think that
that hampers him and particularly this
idea that yield needed to have a quota
that hasn't come up yet today but Yale
needed to have a quota on the number of
women because Yale's job is to produce
leaders
a thousand male leaders and because men
are leaders and women or not or so the
reasoning went why spend any spaces that
you didn't have to on women I I love
that as an example of the insularity
because if he had just looked out his
window in Woodbridge Hall he might have
been able to see down to the law school
where Marian Wright Edelman had
graduated a number of years before where
Hillary Rodham had just started as a
student or down to the Graduate School
where Janet Yellen was getting her
degree so there there were leaders at
Yale even when you women leaders at Yale
even when you arrived but I think that
was hard for some of them and to say yes
Carl hi I'm Sarah Kaufman and I was in
the class of 73 and I wanted to address
this point a little bit on personal
experience and ask the panel to I had
personal experience when I came here and
went around with my brother on a tour
given by Inc Clark and who and I asked
him at the time it was 68 I said are you
I said oh this is perfect I'm I really
want to go here and he said I have the
support of the president not saying to
me we will go co-ed I don't know I don't
think we're gonna be able to do it in
time for you and then of course things
got sped up but I said kingman is for it
and i need we just need a little more
time so to address that i had this word
from the director of admissions as a kid
going around but he was saying he had
the support of the president but to the
question i wanted to ask the panel is
maybe with those of you had experience
of the subsequent yale after we were
here my impression has been that a lot
of the dissatisfaction has been
expressed by students who came after
who expected Yale to be completely ready
for women when they still weren't and
maybe this is ten years out or maybe
even a little less and at least from my
own personal experience I arrived it was
crazy fun we all went into the bathroom
the first time and there were all these
multiple colors and there were urinals
and we said great that's their way of
making the bathrooms for women and it
was funny and we showed up and at least
I didn't particularly care if I was the
only girl and I guess we all knew we
were in for an experiment I'm sure other
people had terrible moments and I'm
saying they didn't but I'm wondering if
those of you who've been involved with
the university as I have in the arts I
have found that this dissatisfaction and
the sounds as if things were worse at
Yale than at Princeton and I know the
tennis team went down there and they
were just you know attacked by the men
overnight in this team so I think that
we can't quite hear you know so I'm
saying that what is your impression
about whether a lot of this
dissatisfaction that's expressed about
the early time is in fact retro thinking
about interviewing women later I tried
something I have a daughter who
graduated in the class of 1986 and a
daughter-in-law got her PhD here in the
year 2000 and I have to say that both of
them resolved their Yale experience they
felt totally accepted my daughter then
went on to the to the architecture
school 15 years later Yale was truly
co-educational but I share with you as
one of the I was in the class of 71
there was a sense that this was an
adventure and
[Applause]
and so lady we didn't have the
expectations that someone even coming
along five years later would have where
Yale felt women felt you know like we'd
been added on tacked on yes right here
hi I'm Marsha Eckerd class of 71 J and I
don't I don't I'm this is more a
question to everybody i I've been
getting the impression and it's perhaps
it's because the class of 73 started out
at Vanderbilt and the rest of us were
sort of I sort of had this image that
they took us like seeds and just threw
us if you had a roommate who was a
friend you did develop a woman friend my
roommate was a white black panther so
she sort of went off and so I have the
feeling that there was more cohesiveness
in the class of 73 I see here of a
number of things that they did together
whereas frankly I didn't really know
nobody here until reunions okay so I
just wondered is that anybody's
impression that the the class of 73 had
slightly more alive but slightly more
experienced together
let's go to one person who was going to
go to this I'm Emily fine class of 73 je
and yes I think definitely there was a
Vanderbilt cult that kept us somewhat
sane but remember all of you talk about
experiment and how exciting it was and
yes indeed it was but we were 17 and 18
and it's isn't really fair to experiment
on 17 18 year old girls so that's
question here that was remark number one
sorry it's not a question question
number two is this morning to me is in
some ways a metaphor for 69 you are
having hundreds of women sit here for
three hours with smaller bladders than
men and whoever arranged as I love you
Eve did not arrange your bathroom check
unless you're all on more Bedrich but
I'm not so anyway just that was just
sort of a funny comment I sort of haha
here we are not enough bathrooms for
women in 69 and not enough bathroom
breaks and today but okay that was just
my sort of observation but I would like
to say I but I would like to comment
about this is a question for the panel
so one of the things that's happened to
me as a New Haven resident all these
years is that people come up to me and
say now that there are you know so many
women at Yale there certainly can't be a
need for an office of women anymore
right and so my question is even though
numbers may have increased I still feel
that just like I felt back then that
although there was excitement about us
coming there really wasn't the support
in terms of mentoring there was no I
didn't feel like anyone reached out to
see if I was surviving I feel that even
though women may be in fact in the
numbers majority now I don't know that
there's still so many specific issues as
we all know about being female on campus
and still a somewhat male-dominated
society and I just feel like as the
Trailblazers here it is our
responsibility
to still stay in touch with with a
woman's experiment you so much I'm gonna
go we have so many people with their
hands up and we only have 15 minutes can
I go just please I'm Susan czerniakow a
1971 Calhoun a new president Peter when
he was sporting a very nice mustache and
hanging out of the grad professional
center way back when I also came back to
Yale and got my PhD much later one of
the things that struck me when I first
came
tl is a lack of women faculty I didn't
realize at the time that overall
nationally only 1 to 2 percent of
faculty members were any University
national average or women but at Yale it
must have been point 1 or something like
that coming from Barnard it was a shock
and I wonder whether any thought went
into increasing the number of women
faculty to develop better parity with
male faculty as a part of co-education
and a larger question looming over our
get-together
I remember hearing back then when I
asked about why there were no women
faculty the answer was well they
couldn't find enough women of quality of
that level at the time to become faculty
members at Yale and now here we are 50
years later and although 50% or maybe a
bit more of the student population are
women we have come nowhere near that
number and women faculty so going back
to the beginning was any thought ever
giving to developing women faculty or
future faculty members at Yale thank you
John I'm handing this hot potato to you
yeah yeah but that wasn't that wasn't my
job description but there was a lot of
talk and indeed there was movement I
mean people like brenda was teaching
there were but it was mostly almost all
at the junior ranks there were efforts
to appoint more adjunct women there are
lots of faculty wives who had their PhD
from this institution but there was no
concerted organized effort now there is
and it's a hard task we've come a long
way we have a long long way to go what
are the figures John do you know a
four-time tenured fat the numbers are
now so what is it now present a salary
is just saying every five years the
ratio shifts you can really see the the
demographics shifting so we break down
the de gender ratio in in five year
increments and in the most recent years
the most recent hiring there's
essentially parity in many many many
fields but but you have a lot of what's
a euphemism very senior faculty where
where the ratios are very skewed still
and but as they move toward retirement
you can see you can see the replacement
I don't have the current number Dean
Chun is behind me and I can see he's on
his cell phones looking it up
right now maybe we'll have it before the
session ends but yeah that's what we
that's what he's looking at I think so
36 percent in the 36 percent tenured or
tenure-track in arts and sciences better
but not there yet yeah you know that
that that's a process that old hiring
process is one that is really stuck in
the 19th century because the the the
faculty and faculty leadership the the
primarily responsible for it the
president doesn't just you know hire but
I know during president Levin's tenure
and I'm sure president salva is
continuing there are actually incentives
provided to the departments to go out
and try their best to get around the
traditional pattern of looking for
people who look like you to succeed you
on on the faculty and there was much
more diversity because of those
incentives that were provided but my
goodness it is a very difficult process
to get people to come out of the
traditional methods of selecting faculty
and that has been one of the reasons
that's been so slow moving on the the
issue of women and and as tenured
faculty members yeah that's true we do
have incentives for hiring women faculty
in fields where women are
underrepresented I should also mention
Yale has 15 Dean's running professional
schools and the Graduate School and Arts
and Sciences and with the appointment of
Nancy Brown as our new dean of the
School of Medicine she will start on
February 1st we now have eight out of
fifteen of those Dean's or women's
[Applause]
my name is Diana Wasserman and I
graduated from Medical School in 1977 I
was admitted to the class of 73 but I'm
speaking with another voice for somebody
who isn't here which was my mother Olga
Wasserman thank you
she would be delighted
[Applause]
thank you very much I have a couple of
comments to make in anticipation of this
weekend I spent some time in her files
and with my memories in the lead-up to
co-education I was a senior in high
school and very much interested in what
was going on I want to say and and this
was stated in in her oral histories she
got along well with kingman brewster she
respected him and I think for the most
part he respected her he didn't know
what he was getting when he hired alga
Wasserman they spent a year or you can
correct me John a couple years traveling
around the country speaking to alumni
groups and selling co-education and she
had quite a few stories to tell that
year she also had an office over at
Strathcona hall where she did speak with
many of you and she spoke with people
who worked for her but also people who
came with problems and I know that and
and she recorded this that at one point
a student come came to her and I don't
know if if that person is here saying
you know I don't know what to do I spoke
to my professor about starting a Women's
Studies program and he said why would we
want to do that we might as well start a
program on the history of dogs and that
that was a you know not common but there
were those elements and there were
elements at Yale
that did not want my mother to be a Dean
because it would demean the position of
Dean my mother and father came to New
Haven in 1948 and for those of you who
who were at Morrie's last night this is
a repetition but my dad got his PhD at
Harvard in the lab of a Nobel laureate
and he came here one of the first Jewish
professors at Yale as an instructor my
mother got her PhD at Harvard in the
same lab of a Nobel laureate although
she said he was very invested in her
career until she got married and then he
figured that she wasn't serious about
science but there were women around who
could be hired on the Yale faculty and
she her efforts on behalf of faculty
members and trying to get more faculty
at Yale may have been why she didn't
have a long-term position at Yale I
don't know but I know that she felt very
strongly about that she felt very
strongly about the fact that there
needed to be more women and that the
number of men would have to be reduced
or new colleges would have to be built
so she was very fond of the people she
worked with at Yale many of whom you're
hearing and will hear over the weekend
and it was wonderful to see John
Wilkinson again to see Sam Chauncey
again and to remember when I would come
from school and meet her in her office
there were always women in the office or
always and in subsequent years always
students who felt that that was a
safe home for them so thank you for your
greeting
thank you so much for adding this and
I'm so glad I caught sight of you around
the podium here congresswoman Jackson
Lee would like to say some moment I'm
gonna talk about bathroom break but but
let me add my appreciation to Elsa's
beautiful daughter and well well-spoken
she is our hero and we thank you so very
much
I like experiments I like being thrown
into a boiling pot and survived it
IV the hot water or cold water but let
me rise particularly I will speak this
afternoon to express my appreciation for
the panel for my sister's fellow
travelers and Kurt Schmoke my fellow
shut the Yale campus down component but
keep it but keep it Gary thank you for
your continued humor and political
satire that has made those of us in this
life know what reality is and Jon Jon
you were our lifeline we appreciate it
very much I'm just gonna make this we
really do appreciate it
president and officers what I would like
to say is a woman of color and - thank
you to all of the women who had the
brilliant idea to bring us together so
the bus driver could say that I didn't
look like I had been here 50 years ago
that was pretty good
[Laughter]
let me clearly say in the toxicity of
which I live in in this world of public
service and this world of attempting to
reach America's Promise I valued the
welcoming with its hills and valleys
that Yael had in diversity in the midst
of all of us was the beginning of the
cultural diversity and the houses that
now exist that those of us who alums who
care about the african-american house
and those who are Latino those were Asia
those who are a variety of advocacies so
in the midst of all of that we should
realize as women there were this
cultural outside world from the Vietnam
War to trials that were right down from
us those of us who were here in that
summer or spring of 70 and a Kingman
Brewster who came over on pilgrims pride
meeting his ancestors I came in a
different boat was able to keep the
stability while this experiment and
while we were trying to find bathrooms
while we were in class and I my children
enjoy me saying that I had to run to my
dorm to use the restroom think that's
all right to be able to say but the
experiment is what I hope as we proceed
through this weekend that we can reflect
on and even maybe leave this place I as
a person who deals with criminal justice
reform you have you have touched my
conscience and so I'm running back now
with a whole new idea about dealing with
the talent that we tried to say get back
into the community hope we all have a
chance to have a conversation I'm
delighted with your work but the point
is I just want to end on the note of
appreciation of this whole weekend I
have some trials and tribulations in the
Congress I have some trials and
tribulations in my own district but I
thought it was important enough to be
able to come to get a better
understanding of how we can utilize this
experiment even now some five decades
later in saying that diversity works
that empowering women works that our
ideas are important and even today in
2019
let it be very clear as we advocate for
the Equal Rights Amendment in the United
States Congress in the America United
America we haven't passed it yet so I
want to thank y'all for being willing to
be in the fight because you're still in
the fight and I want to thank you for
allowing the few women of color
that came in that fall of 1969 to have
voices to experience things that were
unspeakable some of us will talk about
to experience discrimination to
experience embracing to find sisters
that we had never interacted with before
but to be able to attack this thing
called diversity and to realize that
America's promise not yet finished was
we were part of it and what Yale was
hoping to do and I was hoping that
they'd continue to do is to stay part of
the fight for America's Promise I went
on too long I know that you need a
bathroom break but I'm delighted to see
all of you I'm trying to recognize folk
but you all look glamorous fabulous
thank you very much thank you all